[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the samsung galaxy s10 e with a
lowercase e still don't know what the e
stands for officially and the galaxy
s10e it might not be a better phone on
paper than the s10 and s10 plus but i
can definitely say now that i've used it
that it is a better deal it's kind of a
direct answer to the iphone 10r they're
not hiding that in any way like it's the
same price um but hardware wise it's
kind of a step up in every direction
that isn't battery so it kind of got me
thinking
why not just get the s10 so the best way
to explain the s10e is to tell you
what's different versus the regular s10
i'll link the s10 review right here or
below the like button for those who
haven't seen it already uh but it's a
very similar phone
this
is everything that's different so the
big three are the cameras the
fingerprint reader the new display and
the price it's 750 bucks now by the way
i feel like we need a new name for this
like this 750 price because it's not
budget
uh but it's above mid-range still too
but it's also below
flagships like the flagships are like
900 000
so it's above mid-range so it's like a
premium mid-range like a mid-range
premium okay so the cameras s10e has the
exact same primary camera and the exact
same ultrawide camera as the s10 it's
just missing the extra telephoto camera
honestly that's been totally fine i
don't really miss it at all zoomed in
photos will now be digital zoom instead
of switching to the telephoto camera and
that's all right with me and keeping the
ultrawide camera is sweet that's the new
camera for the samsung phones this year
and like i said in the review it's by
far the most fun it is still a bit
softer and a bit more over processed in
those photos than the main camera
definitely not as crispy but this is
something software updates will continue
to improve so that's that with the
camera other than that same really good
camera as we've had in the s10
so then the fingerprint reader instead
of an ultrasonic fingerprint reader
underneath the glass this s10e has a
good old classic capacitive fingerprint
reader on the power button on the right
side of the phone and coming back from
the s10 to using this again
man it's really easy to forget how good
we got at this type of fingerprint
reader it kind of became the gold
standard before we started moving on
from them and we wanted all the screen
space so we started putting them on the
back of the phone and the side but these
fingerprint readers
are really fast this one here on the
s10e is just about one of the fastest
fingerprint readers i've ever used and
there are others that are this fast but
it just feels so much faster coming from
the s10s ultrasonic reader it is way
faster than that now for placement it is
in the power button on the top right
hand side but the power button is still
also kind of high up on the side of this
phone now since the phone is smaller
it's not as big of a deal and with
bigger hands it's even less of a big
deal but just a little bit lower of a
button that would have been perfect so
the reader is basically in a natural
resting position for righties or for
people who hold the phone in their right
hand and on top of that there's even a
gesture in the settings that you can
turn on where you can now swipe down to
pull down the notification shade so that
the fingerprint reader becomes a sort of
a gesture pad and it's super responsive
maybe even too sensitive you can sort of
do it by accident a bunch if you're not
careful but once you get used to it it's
super useful to not have to reach up to
the top of the phone every single time
so basically you pick up the phone and
you just sort of hold it in a natural
resting position it instantly unlocks
and then you have access to the
notifications just like that
i mean it's not as technologically cool
as the underglass ultrasonic fingerprint
reader but
you could argue it's actually better
than what you get on the s10 and some
already have so that brings us to the
last but not least important difference
the display so the s10e has the smallest
display in the new lineup it's a 5.8
inch screen it's still weird to call a
5.8 display small but it's true and it's
still dynamic ammo led still a sharp
high resolution it's 2280 by 1080. still
has a hole punch cut out in the top
corner that makes for amazing wallpapers
of course and still
super bright and color accurate as you'd
expect from a samsung panel the
difference is it's flat so it's a flat
screen now instead of bleeding over the
edges so with that you end up with
slightly thicker more noticeable side
bezels but like
barely and it's all relative still look
at it next to an iphone 10s remember
apple had all that talk about curving
the oled display to get the chin thinner
and to get the edges all really close
s10e has the same size side bezels and
the chin maybe two or three millimeters
taller so that's the aesthetic
difference also one thing i noticed is
the s10e doesn't let you choose your
display's screen resolution like the
bigger s10 does and i'm not actually
sure why i would guess it has something
to do with the pentile display matrix
they're using but either way it's kind
of set and forget out the box anyway and
it looks great so assuming you don't
hate the hole punch this is still a
fantastic display other little things
six gigs of ram in the base model
instead of eight
not really a huge deal i think it was if
it was four
you know thanks to my concerns with the
pixel i would probably be also concerned
about this but six gigs of ram still
seems like enough and you get eight on
the upgraded model so it's pretty close
uh the battery is slightly smaller it's
3 100 milliamp hours instead of the
larger ones on the larger phones but
it's also a smaller display and as you
know that's the biggest power draw so
this is still a pretty great battery
life phone and then uh the color so as
long as we're drawing parallels to the
iphone 10r you might have noticed the uh
the s10e has a bit more color than the
s10 so there's the glass on the back
this is flamingo pink so if you're the
type to rock your phone naked you can
enjoy having an extremely bright phone
even honestly even the red monstro
sensor and all my coloring ability
through your screen probably won't do it
justice it's really pink
but not only that the aluminum rails are
colorized a little bit so you have
matching sides it's more toned down than
the back
but you can see it from the sides of the
phone and then even in the camera module
unlike the s10 they color that metal in
there as well so it's a small touch
black on the s10 color on the s10e but
that that's basically it for this phone
those are the differences
for 750 bucks so again on paper is it a
better phone
no
but it is a better deal matter of fact
feature for feature as far as hardware
which you get and with a much better
display and a headphone jack and all
these other things ultrawide camera i
think it's a better deal than the iphone
10r now for a lot of people that won't
even matter because they just want
another iphone but if you're not too
tight into the ecosystem yet or if
you're looking to get out of it then
why not s10e okay here you should buy
the bigger higher end phone if
you need
the ultrasonic fingerprint reader or
the infiniti display
or
uh the 2x telephoto camera or if you
just have a bigger 200 hole burning in
your pocket
other than that galaxy s10e is probably
the one most people should get
either way that's been it thanks for
watching catch you guys the next one
peace